first of all all feminist bloggers are
uh I don't mean to generalize but
they're all crazy I will generalize they
are all crazy all feminists 100 if every
relationship you've ever had has gone
bad maybe it's not because all the
people you know are terrible maybe you
suck as a human what up guys welcome to
the just Harley things YouTube channel
and welcome to my reaction series today
um I am going to be reacting to Ben
Shapiro debunking every feminist talking
point in nine minutes also guys let's
get 2 000 likes on this video hit that
like button it only takes a second all
right let's go into this do you think
that women who voted for Hillary women
who have strongly substitute women sorry
I gotta say it I think those women are
still the feminist movement and support
of the left are feeling disenfranchised
given the current climate of sexual
brutality and oppression brought to
light in Hollywood recently uh no I
think they're just gonna blame this oh
can we talk about Weinstein so from what
I understand and I could be wrong this
is just off the Dome Weinstein was
saying you could sleep with me to get
apart and let's be honest that's wrong
but all these women were doing it so how
are you a victim if you did it you know
if Weinstein said hey sleep with me to
get this role and nobody did it then he
wouldn't have gotten to do that so if
anything it's more on the women sorry
guys sorry I just I always got to bring
it back to the women it's more on us
because 10 of us sleeping with him or
however many girls slept with him for
the role and there's one of him so who's
the bad guy like there is nothing anyone
could say to me to make me sleep with
them for a role sorry I'll go home
before I do that you know I live at my
parents house well they always blame
because we're all in our own little
bubbles should they feel disenfranchised
100 because in a society no Ben no no I
you know who the real victims the girls
that didn't sleep with them and then him
and then didn't get the roles those are
the real victims I have zero sympathy no
sympathy for a girl that slept with
someone to get a role sorry sorry do you
have any sympathy King no no no that's a
preach sex is transactional in a society
that basically reduces sex to any sort
uh just a physical transaction that is
based solely on consent it makes it very
difficult to explain why it is that the
casting couch in Hollywood is bad per se
right there's actually like a feminist
Theory says that it's bad because of
power imbalances but the sort of
libertarian culture of the left suggests
that power imbalance doesn't have
anything to do with it if I feel like
trading my body for a part in a movie
well that's my business and if you say
differently then you're slut-shaming me
right so let's bring back [__] shaming
Ben well you can't really have it both
ways either it's bad or it's not bad and
if we are going to fight sexual
harassment and sexual assault it seems
to me that we have to do a couple of
things one we have to reinvest tax with
value Beyond just a physical transaction
it's not just two people who are getting
each other's rocks off it actually okay
Ben I'm sorry I gotta do this every time
I gotta do this please bring these back
wait can you look at the date of this
video so it's kind of sad because this
is three years ago and it's like Ben and
all the other conservatives are fighting
this culture war and I want to say it's
gotten better but from three years ago I
genuinely think it's gotten worse
because now we have women with only fans
like that was a that wasn't a thing or
maybe it was just starting when did only
fans start I don't actually know I think
it was roughly three years ago something
beyond that there's a relationship
that's attached to it and beyond that I
think that we need to re-inculcate in
men themselves not just they teach men
not to rape routine one of the things
that's happened is that traditional
masculinity the idea that is a man's job
to protect women this is one of our jobs
as human beings as men to protect women
the feminist movement doesn't like that
well then you can't blame us for not
protecting women if you don't want us to
protect women like I want to protect
women I think men should women I think
one of the reasons God put man on Earth
is to protect women okay well then it is
incumbent on me to protect women but if
you're telling me that I can't even open
a door for a woman because this is
somehow an offense to her honor and then
if I say that it's man's job to protect
women that this is somehow reinforcing
gender stereotypes then don't come
whining to me when bad stuff happens
first thing that I hate today is this
insane piece by some crazy person named
Jody Allard she's apparently a feminist
blogger first of all all feminist
bloggers are uh I don't mean to
generalize but they're all crazy so she
actually has a piece I will generalize
they are all crazy all feminists a
hundred percent called the title of it
is I'm done pretending men are safe even
my sons really and the entire thing is
about how her sons are potential rapists
oh my gosh can you imagine imagine
growing up with a mother that accuses
you of being a potential rapist can you
imagine oh my gosh she says I have two
sons they're strong all these women are
I'm so tired all of these women that
will say oh oh I'm the bad guy this is
the theory and the indoctrination they
let into their house passionate the kind
of boys other parents are glad to meet
when their daughters bring them home for
dinner they're good boys in the ways
good boys are but they are not he's
raised she's raising simps safe boys I'm
starting to believe there's no such
thing she is talking about her own
children being potential ones because of
her culture I have a general
recommendation if you believe that all
men or all women are crazy that
everybody's terrible maybe it's just you
maybe it's just you if every
relationship you've ever had has gone
bad maybe it's not because all the
people you know are terrible maybe you
suck as a human okay and I'm gonna go
with that on this one just my sons won't
unconscious women behind a dumpster and
neither will most of the progressive men
I know but what all of these men share
in common
story I'm just
red pill do you remember that and got
when that brought Turner thing happened
how did she get to the the dumps I'm
gonna revisit that I just have questions
it's a Relentless questioning and
disbelief of the female experience I
didn't realize the common female
experience was to be raped while
unconscious behind a dumpster I know a
few females and I don't know any of them
who've been raped well unconscious
behind a dumpster at least none who have
told me about it and if they did tell me
about that I would say can we find the
person and hunt them down like that'd be
my first reaction can we tell the police
and if not is there a way that we can
kill this person and get away with it
like that seems like the the best
possible like is that not feminist
enough to have to do more of that I do
not want to prove my pain or provide
enough evidence to convince anyone that
my trauma is merited okay if you accuse
someone you might have to provide
evidence of actual you shouldn't just be
able to accuse anyone of any crime
totally insane totally insane
um Child Protective Services needs to
show up like right now at this lady's
door uh thank God it sounds like her
sons are getting old enough that they
get to leave home leave now leave now
okay I will try to find a way to put you
up in your own apartment seriously so
what you actually wrote is you wrote the
Gorsuch like Antonin Scalia is a
proponent of originalism which means he
believes a judge should attempt to
interpret the words of the Constitution
as they were understood at the time they
were written when the Constitution was
written women couldn't own property in
1787 women didn't have the right to vote
it would be 133 years before women won
that fight a fight they fought for 72
years considering women had no rights on
the Constitution which we shouldn't have
gotten which we shouldn't have got I
mean I'm not going to say it but Britain
and there was no mention of women in the
constitution originalism is sexist so
let me ask you first to expand on that
is it the Constitution that sexist or
originalism that sexist or both it seems
that when it comes to women's rights
um originalist perspective tends to
sight on the air of always Looking
Backward backward and not looking at
current day because because they're
trying to because if you're looking if I
wrote a piece of legislation 10 years
ago and I said to you okay are you and I
write a piece of legislation today right
and we use the language of today we mean
something by that language in this
conversation station somebody will read
this 100 years from now and we will have
met what we're saying to each other we
understand what we're saying if somebody
wants to read what we're talking about
today and then it turns out that all the
words that we're using now mean the
reverse because things have changed did
our conversation mean the reverse of
what it meant or does it mean what we're
talking about right now words have
meaning at the time they are said and to
try and read new meanings into Old words
just because quote unquote times have
changed you can end up with some really
bizarre and let's talk about the rights
about most women didn't want the right
to vote because of the responsibilities
that came with the right to vote and so
feminism has always been about the
freedoms without the responsibilities
always always they want special
treatment ultimate and and the problem
here is that you know you like you may
not like what Neil Gorsuch is trying to
do but at least it's a rule of
interpretation in in the Constitutional
structure what we've had is the Supreme
Court very often reversing itself on the
exact same language by using the sort of
rules that you want so for example in
Plessy versus Ferguson you have the
Supreme Court say that the 14th
Amendment did not did not apply to black
people in so far as congregation was
okay and then 50 years after that they
say no it turns out the 14th Amendment
actually meant that segregation is not
okay anymore well that's silly I mean it
either met one or it meant the other it
didn't mean two different things at the
same time one of those decisions is
wrong and one of those decisions is
right that's true for every Judith I'm
feminist there's no idea what he's
talking about
the idea that we can just look to our
hearts to determine what a text meant
200 years ago is is silly when we can
find out what they meant 200 years ago
by reading what they're talking about
now how about the idea that if you're a
woman that you're at some sort of
inherent disadvantage here in the United
States no we are not you're living in
the freeze best place on Earth in
history thank you Ben thank you for
women at any time
hovers over them at all times that only
Hillary Clinton's face can break right
the fact is that in 147 out of 150 the
biggest cities in the United States
women make eight percent more than men
if they are single and unmarried and
have the same degrees they earn more
than that
last question
um
okay I do care about the mother being
poor I do care about foster care okay
abortions because well Planned
Parenthood doesn't prevent abortions
they do perform hundreds of thousands of
abortions a year they perform 300 000
abortions a year they're leading
abortion bill in the United States that
they perform 300
000 abortions a year from Planned
Parenthood that's my evidence they don't
dispute that no one just speaks
birth control I know birth control is
extraordinarily
he can't be based on everything he can't
be based on everything you know none of
the men all the men that follow me
everyone that calls me a grifter okay
I'm gonna say having this take has to
make me not a grifter ban birth control
look I I had to be sold on this I didn't
always think this and there's no way
that metal get behind this you know so
it's just gonna be me by myself but I
just you know I found out today that
birth controls our birth control can
cause abortion so and you know maybe
maybe I was wrong or maybe I don't know
I I heard that from this woman that I
interviewed so you know right wrong I
just don't like to mess with that stuff
I think there's a lot of policies where
again you they're trying to play God and
you know I I don't think I need to be
the most die-hard like scholar to
understand that again a lot of these
policies in my eyes are kind of demonic
because you're trying to play playing is
deciding when you want to have kids
playing God is making contracept like
putting contraceptives in your body to
stop you ovulating like this is abortion
playing God switching genders playing
God all this stuff is playing God
okay they're not the only people in
America who provide affordable birth
control you can go get a pack of condoms
down at the local CVS for 12 bucks
and it's true that most forms of birth
control are also extraordinarily cheap
on an annualized basis unless you have
yeah but at the same time no excuse
ladies it's legal now so if you get
pregnant swear to God your own fault
it's your own fault your problem though
most birth control is very cheap and
readily available and I'm not against
people going and getting that from
Planned Parenthood as you may have
noticed I'm mostly against abortion if
you want to go to Planned Parenthood and
get a contraceptive go for it I don't
care I do care when you start killing
babies this is a problem for me women
really gave up on Marriage a lot too
soon okay marriage was the best thing
ever for women it is an amazing it's an
amazing thing for men too because it
civilizes them and cultures them and
teaches them to be Protectors of their
family and to take care of people and to
think Beyond themselves and to think
beyond their generation women gave up in
marriage a way to teach men to do those
things and also women gave up the idea
that a commitment was going to come
along with this intimacy and let's be
real about this I mean every scientific
study ever done has shown that women
actually do have better sex in the
context of committed relationships all
the crap that you see in Cosmo magazine
yeah it's just it it's pump and dump you
know what I mean it's like it's like how
how good is it gonna be if the dude
doesn't care about you you know like
with 100 guys and being sexually happy
is just you know and I've spoken to a
girl that's slept with a hundred dudes
she said she loved five out of a hundred
dudes five she loved but it is just so I
wonder if that like is a testament
because it seems to be about five times
you can fall in love when I've asked
around it seems to be roughly five and
then you're done forever I guess an
adulterated garbage
[Applause]
and no long answer to a short question
but reinculcation of traditional roles
of male and female with the same
feminist respect that we ought to have
for women at all steps of the process is
the answer thank you
back to all women
sorry Ben sorry I'm sorry I gotta say it
you know I think like five years ago the
conservative movement was a bit blue
pill now it's getting a bit more red
pill sorry the red pill content has
affected the the conservative movement I
yeah I can't respect all women uh cardi
B like how am I supposed to respect
cardi B how should I really I'll be
polite you know I'll say hi I'll be
polite but respect I don't know about
that anyways guys let me know what you
think in the comments also I've been
thinking who are your top five
conservatives of all time because I
thought of another one
um oh my gosh the guy in Texas I forgot
his name
um changed my mind whatever that guy's
name is I Stephen Crowder that's at
Steven Crowder he might have to go in my
top five which means my last top five
will have to change I don't know let me
know in the comments so I can weigh all
the answers given like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time